should you focus on speed or perfection
i got a great question from one of my
youtube viewers pac media who wrote in
long comment basically saying developed
an idea with a professor
could have a huge impact professor
saying wait make it perfect plan it all
out before you launch
and pack media wants to get started make
it fast get it out there right now
entrepreneur mindset and what do i do
what should i do as a question so here's
the thing
you want to embrace a genius at the end
and do both
and the best way to marry that concept
is what's called a minimum viable
product
so this is a product that is good enough
to get out there
it's not some crappy thing you've thrown
together that nobody's interested in
because you have to go speed
is good enough to make a difference but
it's not fully out researched everything
planned out
if you talk to academia
and not to slam on academia
but they're very research driven
right they want everything done if you
look at what they have to do in their
daily lives and create papers and
journals everything has to be cited
everything has to be perfect if you
don't have a great paper with everything
cited you're not going to get published
so that's the mindset they're coming
from
but there aren't too many
academia who are great entrepreneurs
so keep that in mind where you're
getting your advice from
i know you want to get out there
and that's one of the best ways to start
getting feedback is start talking to
your customers build it around their
problems so think about what your
minimum viable product is what does that
look like you have a huge feature list
and and we all have this in our business
we all have a to-do list this big of
things we want to add in things we want
to make better
think about the what needs to be in this
product for people to start picking it
up and finding value in it
that's what you launch with
and launch as fast as you can with that
product and get feedback because no
matter how well you think you're
planning it out you're never gonna do a
great job
i was a victim of this in my business my
first software company we had a great
product okay it was super easy to use is
biotech software helping find cures
in research for cancer and aids and
diabetes and doing great work
the thing that i
spent a ton of time on
and the thing that my development team
spent a ton of time on we thought was
really helpful really valuable super
useful
turns out
that
our audience didn't really care about it
they cared a little bit but it wasn't
great
and my researchers the people on my team
they were in the field right they knew
this stuff it's not like we're just
designing for some customer base that we
don't know about they were the customers
and they built it around something they
felt was a need but we didn't test it
with the market and we ended up spending
a ton of time on this feature that
nobody really cared about where it could
have been better spent on something else
so if i had to make my great plan from
the beginning what i think the product
should look like that would have been it
and a bunch of other stuff would have
been in
and we would have made a mistake
because you can only really judge when
you start talking to your customers and
get their feedback and see if they're
willing to buy it or not
you can have the greatest plan in the
world but if nobody pays you then it's a
sucky plan
and you don't know until you get out
there so don't spend two years making
this great plan only to find out that it
doesn't work
on the flip side you need something to
go and show people
so start talking to them
get out there make your minimum viable
product figure out what features you
need to have in that product
for people to be willing to try it out
and then take their feedback see what
they say and make your product better
and what they suggest may be completely
different than the roadmap you set up
for yourself and that's okay because
you're building it around people who are
going to pay you and that's going to be
your lifeline and help you build a great
company i know it's a struggle i know as
entrepreneurs we want things out quickly
but you got to balance speed versus
perfection
it's a question that'll keep coming back
over and over and over again and the
best way to solve it is building around
your customers
believe and good luck
for those of you watching like the video
thumbs up below thank you guys and i
want to hear you have to think please
leave a comment below i love seeing them
they make my day every day really i love
the comments even if you've never left a
comment today's your day leave a comment
please just saying you love the video or
whatever you have to think and you have
a question for your business leave it
below i'll make a video response thank
you guys i'll see you soon